Thank you.
Thank you very much.
As I said, I
didn't get much sleep because of course I
had to change
the demo in the last moment to get stuff to
work.
So
that's always fun.
And so I'm going to talk about
AirPlay in node, and of course I would like
this to also
work in the browser, so maybe it should just
say
JavaScript, but this is a work in progress,
and
I haven't figured out how to do multi-cast
in the
browser yet, but we'll see what happens.
My name is
Thomas Watson.
You can talk to me on Twitter and
github.
First, a history lesson.
So AirPlay.
There
was a first generation of AirPlay, it was
in 2004, and
it wasn't actually called AirPlay back then;
it was
called Air Tunes.
And actually, Air Tunes is just
a fancy marketing name for a protocol called
RAOP, which
is remote audio output protocol ... I'm feeling
so
sorry for the translators, because I'm kind
of using
a lot of acronyms and protocol names and stuff,
but
hopefully it is going to work out okay.
So RAOP or Air
Tunes is a simple protocol for you have your
computers
before the iPhone, so where like you had your
computer
with iTunes running on it, you have your local
area
network, and you have a RAOP server, which
is usually
like a an airport express and you connect
a physical
speaker to that with an audio cable, and then
you can
stream music from your computer from iTunes
over to your
speaker.
RAOP then came a second generation in 2010,
and it was called AirPlay, because a lot of
stuff
happened between 2004 and 2010: you'd got
the iPhone, we
got an Apple TV, so iTunes -- so AirPlay is
basically an
umbrella name for both iTunes, the Air Tunes
two, and
the protocol called AirPlay, which is under
the umbrella
name AirPlay.
So it is kind of confusing.
But Air
Tunes two, which is a new version of Air Tunes
protocol
or the RAOP protocol, is basically still RAOP,
just
a little bit extended, and it works similarly.
Now it
can also connect your iPhone to your local
area network
and you have an AirPlay server and you can
stream all
sorts of stuff to a TV, as well as a speaker.
So just
to recap, RAOP, that's for audio, AirPlay
is for photos,
video and screen mirroring.
So how does this work?
How does these things figure
out how to talk each other?
There is a service discover
protocol, which is using Apples.
Bonjour protocol,
basically just Apple's branding of something
called Zero
Conf, and it is basically running on top of
multi-cast
DNS, so if we run multi-cast DNS, which we
can, and no
JNS, so we can get started.
Just a quick -- so I'm
going to show you how this will work when
you're using
a RAOP, when you want to play music.
That was the stuff
I was trying to get to work last night.
So the phone
will query, say: is there any AirPlay servers?
And an
AirPlay server will say, "Hey, I'm here, and
I can
support these things, and you can do screen
mirroring or
whatever", and then the phone will be like:
"Cool,
what --" so if it is just concerned about
doing audio,
it will send an RTSP options request, which
is basically
a way for it to ask the server what kind of
RTSP it
supports, and that's basically the protocol
that RAOP
uses to communicate.
It resembles HTTP a lot.
It is
exactly like it, except they change the first
line and
then called it RTSP, it is a proper, so you
can read
about it in a 100-page document if you feel
like it.
The problem is Apple added the thing to the
write, yes?
They added encryption because "Oh no, we can't
use this
protocol and not know who we're talking to",
so this is
for a way for the phone to know: okay, am
I actually
talking to an Apple device here?
This happened in 2011, somebody got the private
key
of off an Apple TV, so that's nice.
So now we can
figure out what's going on.
This is setting a challenge
encrypted using the port key, and we have
to decrypt it
and then have to add to, and past that on
32 bit, and
then we have to add the IP of the server and
the Mac
address of the server, and encrypt that with
the private
key, send it back to the phone, and the phone
is going
to be like: "Cool, you're a proper Apple device.
I trust you."
And then it will send a request, basically
saying:
I'm about to play something to you, and this
is the
codec, and I'm using these bit rates", and
stuff like
that.
And the server will be like: cool.
And it will
be like: okay, I'm almost -- I forgot what
it was
sending here, but it was some extra information,
whatever.
And then it's going to be like: "Okay,
record."
Because it is kind of like this was something
that was built, the RTSP protocol is from
the nineties,
so it is thinking in terms of record and pause
and
rewind, so it is going to send a record request,
and the
server is going to be: cool.
This is all over TCP.
And
then everything is set up, oh yeah, the set-up
thing was
to set up the ports, because now we're going
to switch
to UDP, because it's going to be like you've
got to
output a lot of high quality data, it is going
to be
really fast.
So it is going to set up three different
ports that it's going to listen to, that's
what the
set-up request is for.
On the first port it will send
raw audio packets using UDP.
On the second port it will
send control packets to say: hey, we need
to do this or
this, and the server can also send control
packets back
to say, "Oh, I didn't get that piece of audio,
please
resend it."
And it will also send a heartbeat every three
seconds saying: hey, this is my time, so you
can sync
multiple speakers in the room, and have them
play in
sync.
Then you should have audio, right?
Not really.
Because of this, again, so of course they
encrypted all
the video and they encrypted, it is really,
really -- I
can't say that word here -- stupid.
And trust me, I
spent a lot of time figuring out exactly what
should
be -- how to decrypt this audio, because it
is not
encrypted normally, but still using the same
key, but
you have to decrypt it in 16 byte segments,
and not the
last, and then you have audio.
Not quite, because well,
you have audio, but it is in ALAC, because
if you have
a modern phone or new version of iTunes it
will send it
in ALAC, which is Apple looseless(?) and they
sourced
that in 2011, so that is cool, but it is usually
the
player is used to having it in a container
format.
So
M-peg or something, and this is without the
container
format, so this is why we sent the request
previously.
It will tell us: hey, this is like the bit
rate and all
the stuff, and there's a magic cookie you
need to set.
It is really weird.
You can't just play this normally;
you have to figure out a way to interpret
this ALAC
data.
That was a lot of theory.
But basically RAOP
uses the RAOP client, and server uses four
different
ports some for UDP, some for HTTP RSP, and
they kind of
follow the standards, all of these are backed
by RFCs
but of course Apple changed the last two a
bit, so they
are not really the follow the RFC, and AirPlay
is way
easier is AirPlay over port 7,000 using HTTP.
Thank
you.
And then NTP for screen sharing and syncing
the
sound and video.
And a lot of stuff about protocols.
I thought I'm
going to do this, and it's going to be easy.
And I'm
like: woah.
All of these have an RFC behind them, and
I've been really good at reading RFCs.
Really good.
And these are just like the tip of the iceberg,
all the
audio codec stuff is not here, and video codec
stuff is
not here, so luckily I was not the first one
to do this.
Somebody else already reverse engineered the
protocol
back in 2011, thank you.
But play have changed it a lot
since, so I need to buy this router, I can
do a man in
the middle attack, and on the Apple TV and
I use wire
shock to listen to the packages and stuff.
It is fun.
So getting to the code.
Npm.
I like npm, it is
amazing.
I love npm.
All of this effort I've put into
doing this have resulted in a lot of small
modules that
can be mixed and matched, because I don't
just want to
play or create like an AirPlay server that
you npm
install AirPlay, and then just like have this
magic box
and everything works inside it.
The reason I originally
started doing this was because I wanted you
guys to
figure out fun stuff to do with this.
So all this stuff
has been broken down into small modules that
you can do
depending -- you can use depending on what
you actually
are trying to achieve.
This is just some of them.
So
now it's going to be interesting.
I'm going to take the film first here, and
then I'm
going to, let's see.
How do we do like this?
Yeah?
And then hey, can you wave?
Thank you.
Okay.
So is
this on the screen somewhere?
There it is.
Perfect.
So let's go -- oh, some.
There we are.
Can you see that?
Cool.
So what I'm
going to do is start aircat, and I'm going
to pipe it to
Foo.jpeg.
This is going to be really interesting.
Is
this still on the right network?
I hope it is.
So now
I have the picture here, and what I'm going
to try to do
is -- I'm not in the right network.
Something is wrong.
Let's see.
This is what I feared.
I am a Watson, yes.
Okay.
Yeah.
I feared this would happen.
So of course
this is a demo.
What is supposed to happen is that I
should be able to magically transfer this
photo from my
phone to computer, which is something you
always kind of
have your phone and you have a photo on it,
and you want
to transfer it to the computer, and it is
always like
a pain in the backside.
But apparently my phone is not
picking up my computer.
So we're going to -- I can't
show that right now, unfortunately.
What can be wrong?
Let's see.
Let's do a quick check here.
Mm, yeah.
All
this set-up for nothing.
At least I got a picture.
Laughter].
Remember, drink more water.
Okay.
No fear, no fear.
We can do stuff from the computer
too.
So this what I did last night.
So, the wi-fi is
not working, we're now going to work on -- I
can show
you something that I did last night at 3 o'clock.
So,
back to demo.
I made this route RSP -- I'm sorry, that
name is not that good, but it was quick.
So the idea is
that we set up a server and it will -- I'm
just enabling
debugging mode, which is advertising using
MDNS, I just
realised the clock is not ticking down on
the right-hand
corner there.
I have no idea how much time I have left.
Apparently it is 27 minutes.
Cool.
So, now it is running, so we're going to go
to
iTunes.
And I found some royalty-free music, and iTunes
now, yeah, you zoom like this.
So iTunes now have this,
the name of this speaker that I just set up.
And, okay,
I'm going to play it.
And nothing happens right now
because -- woah -- oh yeah, I'm zoomed in.
That was
why.
Thank you.
So it is sending a lot of
control mechanisms back and forth and right
now
I haven't redirected the output anywhere,
so we can't
hear the audio.
This is on purpose.
I'm going to stop
this.
And then I'm going to use, I'm going to redirect
to standard out, then we use another programme
called
SoX
which is, it's like the only program I've
found that
can actually play back this raw ALAC format.
So it
started, it is waiting for data.
And.
[music plays].
applause].
It is beautiful.
And I can press pause and it
pauses.
This is on the fly, sending data from iTunes
to
a server on the network that happens to be
on my
computer, doesn't matter, streaming out raw
ALAC to
standard out, SOX is reading it from standard
in, and
playing it back using audio.
So it is like okay, job
done.
It is now one o'clock at night, and I was
like:
mm, I wonder what else you could do?
Then I thought
back to note conference a couple of weeks
back, me and
Matthias Mackintosh on github, and we were
talking about
how you can do live dreaming of torrents,
and I'm not an
expert, he is the live streaming torrent expert,
those
of you who know him know that.
He is in the States
right now, so I looked him up and said: hey,
we should
really make this thing work with torrents
because then
what we can do is we could put an Internet
bubble in
between the playing devices and the output
devices, then
we can just stream this all over the Internet.
So we
did that.
From one to three.
So let's see.
What I'm
going to do now is I'm going to just open
another
console here, but this, you have to believe
me, could
work across the Internet.
Okay.
So he made this
wonderful thing called peervision, and there
was a seal
called peervisionary, which basically allows
you to live
stream torrents, which is tricky if you think
about it
because torrents, you can't change the content
of
a torrent, that doesn't work any more, you
have to
produce a new one, but this works using some
clever
stuff that he can tell you about.
What is it called?
Something with curves and encryption.
So, shall we
remove the debug flag here?
No let's keep it here.
We
tried to use this debug the data, but it is
not
necessary.
The hotel Internet was really slow.
So
peervision will give me -- basically, if you're
familiar
with magnet link in torrents, this is my magnet
link,
now a private key that we can use, and now
it says the
DHT is ready, and let's play that.
Now we attach a peer
to the swarm, like this, and then we go in
to play the
music.
Then hopefully it is just going to buffer
a little bit and use the Internet -- what
are you
saying?
FROM THE FLOOR: You're using the wrong peervision.
THOMAS: Oh yeah, don't reuse the -- okay.
It is like these.
Woah.
Okay.
[music plays]
And the cool thing about this is now that
my --
thank you, sound guy.
Now that my peer is actively
streaming this and receiving it, what I can
do is I can
join like a new peer to the network
and they will all
-- it sounds terrible -- but they will all
now both play
the same audio, and they will all help each
other stream
the packets so that the more people who join,
the less
load it is on the server, just like this.
music stops].
[applause].
How much time do I have left?
Two minutes?
Okay.
It's terrible that this thing didn't work,
but what are
you going to do?
You do some torrent stuff instead,
right?
Live streaming torrents.
Awesome.
So, thank
you.
[applause].